you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the director
of the demos think tank polly mckenzie
and the daily mail's deputy political
editor john stevens they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages now
the mirror says that the police have
been handed a photo of the prime
minister with a lager at a downing
street party and that it was taken by
the taxpayer-funded number 10
photographer
the time says there's a civil war in the
cabinet with boris johnson being urged
to sack the chancellor rishi sunak
the political terms the i describes the
prime minister as isolated and suggests
mr sunak is taking center stage
isolated is also the word of the day for
the guardian which reports on mr
johnson's efforts to rally his team
the financial times carries accusations
of hypocrisy against the governor of the
bank of england andrew bailey who has
recommended that people shouldn't seek
pay rises in the current economic
climate
the telegraph has word of an apology
from british gas to hundreds of
thousands of its customers for failing
to properly maintain their boilers over
the winter
and the mail claims some department of
health staff were told in emails that
they only needed to come to the office
for a minimum of four days
a month
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and john stevens welcome to you
both good evening hope you're both well
let's start with the
mirror um and this uh photographic
evidence has uh come forward it seems
and been handed to the police that was
rumored that there were photographs to
be shared and they have now materialized
on the front of the mirror polly
well i mean
so much of this information is there in
the headline
in a way what's fascinating about this
party around the prime minister's
birthday is that it was reported at the
time and it wasn't a big deal but so
much has changed because of what we've
discovered about this
culture
and the repeated kind of law law
breaking or lockdown breaking that
happened that even tiny little sort of
drippy bits of information like this
give us an opportunity to
rehash it all over again the prime
minister by this account has there is a
picture of him rishi sonic is apparently
standing next to him holding a soft
drink
and there's something about the fact
that it appears to have been taken by
the official photographer these these
are taxpayer-funded photographs of this
uh lockdown breaking not just sort of
casual snaps that might have been taken
on staff's phones i mean this story has
just goes on and on and on my daughter
is ten she has written a satirical song
about the boris party it's like because
but because it's cool in the playground
to laugh at the prime minister about
parties like you know it's like the new
squid game it's hilarious to 10 year
olds
which
is unfathomable right and yet it's a
sense that the whole country considers
this to be a bit of a joke and and this
is yet another another even though it's
quite a small blow i think it it runs
the story for another day doesn't it
polly we'd love to get the lyrics of
your daughter's song
you can get those together for us before
the the 11 o'clock hour um to you john
the fact that there was an official
photographer um which suggests that
there wasn't any um any semblance of
hiding what they were doing or that the
party was something that should be kept
under covers it sort of adds insult to
injury doesn't it
yeah and this is a bit of a side issue
that you know why on earth are we as
taxpayers paying for a photographer to
take pictures of the prime minister in
private having a birthday cake i mean
i'm not sure
at a time when everyone's signing their
bounce that's really the best use of our
money but i think the real problem here
is that there are all these pictures out
there we heard last week that there were
300 photos that sue grey the senior
cabernet's office official who's looked
into this has handed over to the police
and i think that the worry for a lot of
tory mps is that they're just not able
to draw a line under this rail boris
johnson was hoping he'd have this report
with sue gray he'd come out with his
plan of his fight that what was he going
to do differently a lot of mp's are just
thinking this just never goes away and
they'll be thinking now what about if
some of these photos start to trickle
out i mean the mirror today they've got
this story about how this photo exists
they don't actually have the photo yet
but if the photo got out there then we'd
have a whole nother route about this the
government would be dealing with it
again and we'll be getting on with
dealing stuff like costs of living cobia
et cetera et cetera and i think that's a
real worry for back benches this just
goes on forever and it never ever ends
and polly we hear this evening that uh
nick gibbs the former schools minister
submitting um another letter about no
confidence in the prime minister
yeah nick gibb who i mean as far as i
can tell seems to have served as schools
minister about 37 years
um or at least
um consistently since since 2010 you
know incredibly long-serving minister
widely respected within the conservative
party very sensible very measured not a
bombastic guy at all
so for him
to have
made this step somebody who has been not
just loyal to boris johnson but loyal to
theresa may loyal to david cameron i
think it it will
uh send a ripple of some sort through
the more sensible and serious members of
those conservative back benches that you
know there there is a line that that in
the end you cannot cross
john the times are telling us that
there's a civil war in the cabinet uh
the the article describing um rishi
sunek as being on maneuvers and being
less than loyal and also the same being
said of sajid javid
yeah so this is we had rishi sunak out
yesterday
this is this row over jimmy savile and
kia starman whether it was right for
boris johnson to say that it was
starmar's fault that jimmy savile hadn't
been prosecuted while he was alive and
we had rishi soon account yesterday he
was saying he wouldn't have said that
which is i think the first time that
we've had rishi soon that directly
criticized the prime minister in public
we've had sajid javid out today
he was asked about it he went out his
way to be
very nice about kierstama he said he'd
done a good job when he led the crown
prosecution service
and you know that's a real striking
difference between that and boris
johnson with what he said the other day
but the question is what happens now and
the times suggesting that some people in
the cabinet
want boris johnson to sacrifice you soon
at i just can't see that happening you
know rishi sooner is very popular on the
tory back benches a lot of people see
him as someone who could potentially
take over from boris johnson and whilst
there might be a lot of people in the
tory party who think he's been disloyal
and think they might be less likely to
vote for him in a leadership election
because of this
i just don't think that boris johnson
has got the authority anymore to be able
to sack someone like wishy sooner i
think if he did that he'd be scared that
his whole government would quickly
collapse because there would be other
ministers that would follow and then it
would create a massive rally wouldn't be
able to survive um polly the eye saying
that rishi soon excuse me women's
greater influence over direction of
government than ever before um headline
there saying that he is taking center
stage
well there's no question that downing
street is
distracted uh downing street also as of
this week barely has any senior staff in
it
and so that that vacuum of both the
prime minister and the team's
distraction
means that rishi sunak has more power he
is pretty much one of the most poles the
most popular politician in the country
whether that would survive him you know
during a leadership election whether he
would in fact be a good and popular
prime minister completely different
question i think but at the moment he is
still popular he is liked
and and whilst the prime minister is
kind of on his uppers that does change i
think quite a lot of the dynamic in
westminster and in whitehall
um john's completely right i think that
the prime minister is not in a position
to be making
big aggressive moves to get rid of his
enemies in the conservative party you
know he he chopped great chunks off the
conservative party to get brexit done
and told people like ken clark that they
weren't welcome in the conservative
party literally booted them out
uh and and so he you know though he's
got a larger electoral coalition he's
got a smaller kind of intellectual
coalition within the conservative
parliamentary party and if he starts
trying to chop off great chunks of
additional people because they also have
the wrong view about parties or the
wrong view about leveling up or the
wrong whatever it is he's gonna end up
completely alone um and you know in the
end that's not how you run a government
you have to command the the confidence
of the house of commons and and that's
about leadership but it's also about
recognizing that you have to bind
together people who disagree with you on
quite a lot of stuff that's not a skill
boris johnson has had much in the past
but it's the one he needs now if he
wants to survive
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me paul mckenzie and
john stevens there they are let's have a
look at the financial times uh bailey
accused of pay rise hypocrisy this is
the governor of the bank of england
andrew bailey uh being criticized by
downing street call for restraint on
increases in pay unions reacting angrily
um why the hypocrisy though
john
so the hypocrisy is because andrew
bailey earns 575
000 pounds a year which is 18 times the
average salary so he's not really the
right person to be out there making this
argument and what he's saying is that if
workers all ask for big pay rises then
that will lead to higher prices and you
know then we'll keep getting inflation
spiraling and then
you know keep going round and round in
circles
and so he doesn't have an argument here
that in order to
stop inflation getting out of control
it wouldn't be a good thing for people
to just keep getting massive pay rises
then prices going up and going round and
round in circles
however if you earn more than half a
million pounds a year you'll not want
the right person to deliver that message
especially to people who are currently
struggling
with all the rising prices in the dark
the threat of the price going up
and you know if you're on a low income
and you've got those things going on
you're going to ask for the biggest pay
rise you can possibly get and
realistically it's probably not going to
be that big but if you're really
struggling to make things add up and
then you hear andrew bailey saying this
when you earn so much money i think you
just think it's a total joke
polly uh just playing devil's advocate
for it for a moment does that the size
of his salary matter if the advice he's
giving is correct
in a way not at all
um but the question is first of all is
the advice that he's given correct is
the bank of england taking the right
approach on inflation
a lot of the inflationary pressures seem
to be coming from supply constraints
which we
can expect may we hope unwind over the
next few months a big chunk of it comes
from energy prices which aren't then
connected in the same way into that kind
of consumer demand
that creates the cycles of inflation
that he is worried about and you know
lots of
much
more thoughtful and clever economists
than i certainly are are questioning
some of their their judgment and their
approach at the moment to managing this
potentially quite huge inflation shock
that you know nine months ago they were
telling us was uh not gonna happen
on the on the inflationary point though
let's just assume that he's right and
that we do need to get people to try and
kind of uh tighten their belts in that
way try and be as measured as possible
in the pay rises they offer as employers
and the pay rises they ask for and try
and keep prices down well then he's just
not the right messenger
because whether whether it's justified
or not lots of people will take the
reaction that john's just described
frankly he'd pay against but it's a lot
more than i do this um andrew bailey so
i feel a bit of that kind of politics of
envy as well so he's not the right
messenger if this message matters
you actually need to think much more
creatively about how are you going to
build bridges of relationships with
those trade unions with uh with citizens
who are the right messengers and and not
be so i guess tiered as to imagine that
you
rich guy standing on the steps of the
bank of england lecturing people about
their wages is the way to get this thing
you say is important to actually happen
yes it's